pascal canfin numéro deux sur la liste
macro nistre renaissance est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir soirée
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous d'avoir
répondu à l'invitation de la fp du
figaro des chaînes parlementaires avec
moi ce soir pour vous interroger sur
votre campagne sur ses difficultés aussi
et puis sur le programme écologique du
chef de l'état une nouveauté lors de sa
conférence de presse pierre lepeltier du
figaro et pour le brio de la sp
messieurs bonsoir brigitte boucher de
lcp assemblée nationale nous rejoindre à
tout à l'heure et puis bien sûr la
séquence des parlementaires pour vous
interpeller dans un instant pascal
canfin
ce soir le sénateur communiste pierre
laurent et le député et l'ère rafael
celle berger et puis bien sûr comme
chaque semaine les internautes du figaro
peuvent réagir sur le chat du journal et
bien sûr je me ferais l'écho de vos
interpellations et de vos interrogations
pascal canfin vous avez tout à l'heure
avec votre tête de liste évidemment
déposé votre liste officiellement
comment est ce que vous qualifiez votre
entrée en campagne est ce que vous la
jugez dynamique ou plutôt poussive
écoutez vous rire est une réponse déjà
c'est la question qui appelle une
réponse très orientée dans sincèrement
quand je regarde les sondages qui valent
ce qu'ils valent mais on est aujourd'hui
autour de 22 23 % à égalité certains
disent qu'on est devant certains disent
qu'on est derrière la liste du
rassemblement national
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est assez
stable depuis plusieurs semaines vous
essayer de conjurer le mauvais sort quel
scénario noir ne dépassez pas et je sais
pas seulement le mauvais sort pour la
liste renaissance c'est le mauvais sort
pour la france c'est que ça fait cinq
ans que le rassemblement national front
national est le premier parti la
première délégation de france à
bruxelles et à strasbourg au parlement
européen ces cinq ans c'est une perte d'
influence pour la france qui est
dramatique dramatique parce que comme le
front national rassemblement national
étant l'opposition à tout tout le temps
partout
il n'a aucune espèce de poids et comme
s'ils représentent en majorité à la
france ça veut dire que la france perd
énormément de l'enfant forme
manu sur votre campagne si je verrai
possible d'aménager maintenant je vous
ai répondu sur le fait que les
finalement c'était assez stable les mois
je suis pas là pour faire la coupe de
bois je peux vous dire que tout va bien
quand tu vois pas bien et vert versement
c'est juste que vous dire que ça fait
les quand on regarde les sondages et les
enquêtes d'opinion c'est ce que pensent
les français
il ya aujourd'hui un duo un duel pardon
excusez moi plutôt qu'individuelle
excusez moi un duel entre le
rassemblement national d'un côté et la
liste au renaissance de l'autre et la
vraie question politique de ces
élections c'est de savoir qui va gagner
à la fin est ce que ce sera deux
nouveaux comme en 2014 de front national
une perte pour la france où est ce que
enfin on pourra peser davantage au
parlement européen pour transformer
l'europe de l'intérieur c'est évidemment
notre venue pendant le duo c'est celui
que vous formez avec une télé loisirs
seule une telle situation
alors si la campagne natale et l'oiseau
commence à être marquée par plusieurs
polémiques
il y en a une la semaine dernière où
mediapart révélait qu'à la figure son
nom a figuré sur une liste d'un syndicat
d'extrême droite lors de ces étudiante à
sciences po
est ce que finalement cet épisode là ne
remet pas en cause sa légitimité dans ce
combat que vous venez de décrire
contrôlés contre le rassemblement
national
si ce que nathalie loiseau a fait il ya
35 ans avaient un impact sur ce qu'elle
l'est aujourd'hui
si ça disait quelque chose de ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui alors oui vous auriez
raison mais ce qu'elle a fait il ya 35
ans moi j'avais 10 ans et si ça n'a
aucun impact si ça ne change rien à ce
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui à ses
convictions à ses valeurs à son
engagement d'aujourd'hui
bah voila je sais pas ce que vous
faisiez il ya 35 ans paradoxalement ça
renforce aujourd'hui sa capacité de
résistance à l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je peux parce que je la
côtoie tous les jours je peux témoigner
de son engagement absolu absolue sans
faille sans limite à combattre l'extrême
droite non seulement en france mais en
europe et c'est ça qui m'intéresse dans
la toile il oiseaux aujourd'hui c'est
pas son parcours il ya 35 ans quand
chacun en faisait un chauffeur et h ça
fait peut faire sa vraie tâche si ça
disait quelque chose aujourd'hui ça ne
dit rien de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et je peux vous témoigner
vous le devant les auditeurs et les
téléspectateurs du fait qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a aucune ambiguïté sur
l'engagement d'aujourd'hui pascal canfin
vous déposer la liste mais toujours pas
de programme mais programme ni la drague
9 mai à priori quinze jours avant les
élections avant le scrutin c'est pas un
plein jour c'est un droit oui certes
mais quinze jours avant tous les autres
partis ont présenté leur programme pas
bon alors je vais pas me cacher derrière
mon petit doigt
il y avait un problème de cohérence avec
les annonces du grand débat enfin de
sortie du grand débat c'est évidemment
pour ça qu'on l'a décalé de quelques
jours parce qu'on n'allait pas sortir
les mêmes les mêmes semaine notre
programme sur les européennes quand
l'attention était focalisée sur les
annonces du grand débat maintenant la
journée de l'europe c'est symbolique
d'une part et d'autre part on peut
parler du programme on va pas attendre
le 9 mai puisque nous avons déjà dit
publiquement ce que nous allions
défendre on va y revenir je l'espère sur
les questions environnementales
on a déjà dit ce qu'on allait défendre
sur les questions sociales et puis ya
déjà des pleins de choses qui sont dans
le débat sur la lutte contre les paradis
fiscaux sur leur budget pour la zone
euro sur le droit d'asile européen et
sur le lire un cratère sur la maison
france et la maison europe puisque ça
c'était nouveau dans le discours dans la
conférence de presse du chef de l'état
ça vous le prenez également votre donc
il ya le la prise en compte du rejet de
l'immigration
alors justement ce qui était intéressant
le chef de l'état s'est intéressé à
prouver ce qu'il a dit là c'est que
c'est enfin là si on a l'impression que
là il s'inspirait plutôt de monsieur
bellamy dans le grand débat c'est pas un
sujet qui est revenu en tête mais les
priorités des sauf que le chef de l'état
en a parlé la semaine est d'accord mais
je réponds à votre question c'est ça
c'est intéressant parce que ça veut dire
que contrairement à ce qu'on voudrait
nous faire croire il n'ya pas d'hystérie
collective dans le pays
autour de ce sujet et vous avez des
centaines d'exemples sur les territoires
dans des villes petites moyennes voire
dans des villages où vous avez de
l'accueil de réfugiés syriens afghan
autres qui se passe très bien mais je
savais que manuel
votre programme emmanuel macron a durci
le ton sur la question de l'immigration
de la dépossession culturel est entendue
il ya un équilibre
sincèrement c'est l' équilibre de la
liste et je pense que c'est l'équipe
dans la société c'est à dire on
hystérise pas ce sujet parce que ça ne
peut que nous mener dans une impasse
collective nécessairement mais on n'est
pas non plus des naïfs dix ans il suffit
d'ouvrir les frontières
yakafocon tout va bien il n'y a pas de
problème non c'est on défend nos valeurs
nos valeurs elles sont sur le droit
d'asile et je peux vous faire des
propositions concrètes sur le goût de
l'effort et au cv on défend les
frontières et on défend les frontières
et c'est le point d'équilibré qui est le
bon en france qui est le bon
politiquement pour continuer à vivre
ensemble avec une identité ouverte sur
le monde mais quand même
clairement on rentre pas n'importe
comment dans un pays quel qu'il soit et
compris la france sur aucune raison
qu'on ne soit une exception dans le
monde et ça on le fait de manière
sereine je crois que c'est vraiment ça
l'essentiel c'est que les débats sur
l'immigration
si vous lister risée quelle que soit la
position que vous prenez de toute façon
ces perdants pour construire une bonne
solution que les coeurs vous parlez de
la fin du grand débat il ya un des
thèmes qui est finalement peu revenu
dans la bouche du président jeudi
dernier c'est l'écologie est ce que vous
pensez qu'on aurait pu aller plus loin
encore alors moi je pense par
construction parce que c'est le combat
de ma vie avec la construction
européenne que il faut aller plus loin
bien évidemment et puis parce que tous
les scientifiques du monde tous les
climatologues nous disent attention on
est en train de rater l'objectif est de
perdre la bataille donc oui il faut
aller plus loin et aucun gouvernement au
monde n'en fait assez aucuns y compris
en france
mais maintenant ce qui est intéressant
et c'est compris en france où ils
compris en france on en fait évidemment
pas assez la question l'accord de plus
ne va pas laisser le pays de l'accord de
paris n'en fait pas assez et c'était
vrai sous françois hollande c'était
aussi vrai avant l'accord de paris sous
nicolas sarkozy et c'est vrai
aujourd'hui sous emmanuel macron c'est
vrai par contre la question est de
savoir si on est parmi les meilleurs
dans un contexte où personne n'en fait
assez quelle que soit la couleur
politique du gouvernement accorde de
gauche de droite du centre ou est-ce
qu'on est parmi les plus mauvais élèves
et là je vous ai apporté un tableau que
je trouve très intéressant parce que
c'est une analyse qui est fait par les
rappels le réseau action climat européen
donc l'association des le collectif des
associations environnementales
européenne a remontré on n'est pas dans
un jeu de politique politicienne
française et on voit quoi on voit que
c'est ce que je vais vous dire aucun
pays ne fait ce qu'il faut faire 100%
aucun personnes par contre il ya la
france est 3e 4e jusque là c'est le
premier dans le troisième pays pop3
suisse yeux suède pardon portugal france
ça veut dire que les associations
environnementales européennes
pas moi 10 la france est aujourd'hui le
troisième pays en europe de par son
ambition environnementale et ses
politiques environnementales
donc oui ça n'est pas assez et je vous
dirai jamais que c'est assez parce que
nous à toujours aller plus loin par là
mais on est parmi les plus actifs et les
plus ambitieux en europe c'est pas moi
qui le dit ce sont les associations
environnementales c'est ça la
réalisation en tout et pour tout une
ovation sur l'écologie c'est vrai que
j'ai naturellement non parce qu'il ya
ces mesures je crois mesures
fondamentales qui n'ont pas forcément
été appréciées à leur juste valeur par
les associations justement porté en
partie par les associations et donc je
suis là aussi pour expliquer cette
mesure mais quel canton des zooms d'une
mesure en par bâle iii qui ont été
annoncées la première l et pas seulement
écologique mais elle est fondamentale
c'est la suppression des grands corps je
reviens là dessus l'état aujourd'hui le
fonctionnement de l'état est
complètement capturés par une élite qui
est extraordinairement homogène sur le
plan social l'accord qui représente une
toute petite partie de la société
française très parisienne et même au
sein de paris les quelques rares en
glissement de un frein à la transit je
pense c'est le jeu de celle ci non non
pas du tout je vais venir
je pense que si on veut construire de
l'innovation
si on veut faire monter les solutions
qui existent sur le territoire sur les
territoires dans les régions sur les
questions environnementales dans les
banlieues sur l'isolation des bêtes des
pavillons de banlieue etc
toute chose que les collectivités
locales porte fortement mais qui ne sont
qui ne changent pas d'échelle pourquoi
parce que vous avez là une énorme zone
conserve de conservation de l'existant
quand les deux autres mesures là mais
c'est important d'accord mais on dit
d'accord aucun gouvernement
en france aucun ne s'était attaqué à ce
que les français y voient la mairie au
sort ce soir ça c'est la deuxième mesure
ne voit pas nécessairement s'y voit pas
nécessairement quand on parle de
l'inspection générale des finances
dick ont encore ça parce que c'est je
peux vous dire je les fais là que j'ai
vécu à l'intérieur j'ai été ministre
pendant trois ans je peux vous dire à
quel point il ya là une force de
résistance et que emmanuel macron est le
premier président à s'y attaquer premier
élément deuxième élément le conseil de
défense écologique on sait que vous
coupez dont yannick jadot dit que c'est
prendre les français pour des andelys
scola hulot prend la défense
c'était hier où on le soutient qu'ils
portent des grosses réserves sur ce
conseil j'ai pas eu entendu et très
honnêtement sa réaction bas je vous
prends l'écologiste que je connais bien
qui s'appelle nicolas hulot c'est quoi
qui justement c'est d'abord c'est pas du
tout un comité puisque c'est le
gouvernement dans sa dent de songer à
dans sa quintessence dans son essence
pour transformer le modèle économique
pour aller vers quelque chose de plus
écologique vous avez aujourd'hui le
conseil de défense d'accor qui s'est
réuni une fois par semaine
mystère de l'intérieur ministre ou
ministre ministre des affaires
étrangères est mise la défense par un
comité théodule c'est les quatre cinq
ministres et le premier ministre et le
président bien évidemment qui sont au
coeur de la protection de nos frontières
de la lutte contre le terrorisme et
c'est l'enjeu climatique nécessite que
l'on réorganise l'état j'en ai parlé
pour les grands corps et qu'on
réorganise aussi la façon dont le
gouvernement fonctionne sur ces sujets
pourquoi parce que l'écologie c'est
transversal
ça ne peut pas être juste un ministère
le ministère de la transition écologique
et solidaire en l'occurrence qui peut
imaginer que l'on puisse faire vraiment
la transition écologique si bercy n'est
pas à bord midi de l'économie liste des
finances mise de l'agriculture ni du
logement on me disait transport etc
et donc ce conseil de défense écologique
ça va permettre de rassembler les dix
quinze acteurs clés la caisse des dépôts
les opérateurs publics l'ademe et v etc
avec les quatre ou cinq ministères clés
et là à ce moment là on va réussir à
gagner la bataille contre le
gouvernement l'a réussi à gagner jusqu'à
présent les premiers au monde à faire ça
quand nicolas hulot donné leur donnez
moi un autre exemple dans une
institution celle là c'est le
gouvernement situation c'est dans le
fonctionnement du gouvernement et de
défense il existe le conseil de défense
écologique on est premier pays au monde
à dire on va réorganiser la façon dont
on fonctionne parce qu'on n'y arrive pas
à la hauteur de l'enjeu
roger la troisième mesure que bublé la
troisième mesure c'est le conseil de la
participation citoyenne et là qu'est ce
que c'est de dire on prend 150 citoyens
tirés au sort représentatifs de la
société française et ce qui en sortira
sera soumis au vote de l'assemblée
nationale parlement hook ou à leurs fins
pascal canfin merci de le retrouver
votre fusil et ma passion et votre page
c'est vous qui les avez soufflé avec lui
au chef de l'état a non pas ce qu'il dit
ça ça a pu m'arriver d'en discuter vous
l'avouer ou l'avouer effectivement j'ai
proposé ces mesures mais pas tout seul
avec emmanuelle wargon avec nicolas
hulot avec françois de rugy
parce que moi je crois à l'action
collective monsieur grossiord jamais à
l'action individuelle paul pour en
revenir aux enjeux de la campagne
etes-vous concurrents notamment c'est
raphaël glucksmann intéressant ce que ça
c'est pas un enjeu par exemple nom de la
campagne d'accord pas des européens c3i
alors à l'enjeu de la campagne
européenne ce qu'ils font des
propositions agrégeront continental a
perdu raphaël glucksmann propose un
impôt de 25% sur les bénéfices des
sociétés
et puis une taxe sur le kérosène pour
les vols intra européens
selon lui ça permettrait de rapporter
milliards d'euros qui financerait
précisément les nouvelles budget
nécessaire pour les projets
environnementaux savalan bon sens c'est
la bonne solution c'est les bonus et ça
ça va dans le bon sens mais c'est pas
forcément la voie la plus facile et donc
la plus efficace
moi si je suis revenu en politique c'est
j'ai fait le choix de l'efficacité
l'efficacité c'est d'abord d'être sur la
liste qui je l'espère gagnera et qui
donc emportera le plus de députés
européens qui aura 3 peser au maximum
parlement tout le monde de faire le
meilleur score ils ont fait quand vous
êtes à trois à quatre à cinq essais dont
on voit bien que votre capacité à peser
demain et quand même pu limiter votre le
plus écolo
tant mieux alors ça ça pour le coup si
je peux me permettre cette répondre à
cette petite fille la situation rapide à
la question je l'écologie c'est un bien
commun
ça appartient à tout le monde donc ça
n'appartient à personne
donc moi je me réjouis que les est que
les énergies s'additionnent je me
réjouis que les mêmes le localisme
défendu par le rassemblement sincère oui
mais quand je vois les alliés du front
national quand je vois que tout ce
qu'ils défendent au niveau international
ils se sont réjouis l'élection donald
trump donald trump comme grand écologie
je pense qu'on fait mieux
ils se sont réjouis de l'élection de
gaulle sonar au brésil lors grotte
écologie je pense qu'on fait mieux
je pense que il serait proche de poutine
comme grant écologie je pense qu'on fait
mieux donc l'hypocrisie totale du
rassemblement national sur ce sujet hier
sa fin ça va pas tenir très longtemps de
toute façon de grandir le mot localisme
alors que dans toutes les propositions
qui sont faites et dans le classement
des ong par ailleurs il arrive
systématiquement dernier donc sur
monsieur d'axa sur les bénéfices d'une
parade mais pourquoi c'est pas la voie
que nous nous avons choisi
je me permets de trois chiffres si c'est
possible la commission européenne a
évalué les besoins financiers qui
manquait
chaque année pour que notre économie
investissent dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique à la hauteur de
ce qu'il faut faire et de ce que les
scientifiques nous demande de faire
c'est 200 milliards d'euros par an
publics et privés entreprises et
particuliers dans leur logement dans
mille milliards sur cinq ans
200 milliards d'euros par an on peut
aller les chercher par exemple avec une
taxe carbone aux frontières sur les
importations on peut aller les chercher
avec une taxe sur les transactions
financières pour alimenter une partie
d'un budget européen au budget de la
zone euro mais on peut aussi de 100
milliards d'euros par an plus simplement
un ordre de grandeur pour la france ça
fait à peu près 20 25 milliards c'est le
pipe ces deux mille milliards
ça fait donc 1 % à peu près 1% de la
richesse totale qui est créée chaque
année qu'il faut investir davantage dans
l'écologie consultants et or moi
j'apporte ce taxi une taxe je sais ce
que je vous dis il peut y avoir des
recettes fiscales supplémentaires tipp
taxe carbone aux frontières taxe sur les
transactions financières premier point
donc là on peut rejoindre je pense assez
largement ce qu'ils proposaient par
d'autres listes et tant mieux parce que
là parce que quand une fois nous sommes
unis
deux rassemblements quand la france et
rassembler la garde tant mieux tant
mieux parce qu'au delà de cette bataille
on la gagnera ensemble on l'appellera
ensemble donc tant mieux on fédère les
énergies
c'est formidable et de toute façon au
parlement européen il faudra qu'on
trouve une majorité autour de ces sujets
donc c'est pas une seule liste tout seul
qui à la vérité révélée et qui doit
incarner ça tant mieux si ça recoupe
d'autres propositions par contre pour
financer ces 20 milliards de plus
d'investissements dans l'économie
il faut mobiliser différentes énergies
en france la caisse des dépôts en europe
la banque européenne d'investissement et
c'est pour ça que notre proposition
principale sur l'écologie en europe
c'est de créer une banque européenne sur
le climat qui permettra de levier cet
argent qui ensuite va arriver dans les
entreprises dans les pme dans les
infrastructures dans les ménages pour
transformer notre modèle coeur est ce
que vous considérez que votre liste
renaissance et quelque part la plus
pragmatique en terme d'écologie
parce qu'effectivement si pragmatiques
ça veut dire peu d'ambition alors la
réponse est non la plusieurs bragg
métriques vous l'appelez ambitieux ça
veut dire j'ai un cap très clair
respecter l'accord de paris faire en
sorte que mes enfants et nos petits
enfants vivent dans un monde qui est
juste vivable humainement parce qu'un
monde à 5 degrés c'est un monde
chaotique
si c'est ça l'ambition oui c'est ça
notre ambition mais pour y arriver
par exemple on pense qu'on n'a pas
besoin de changer les traités européens
comme jean luc mélenchon parce que sinon
c'est à dire que le premier combat c'est
d'abord de sortir du capitalisme et de
changer les traités européens puis quand
on aura fait ça alors on pourra
commencer à lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique ça pour le coup c'est
totalement non pragmatique et finalement
totalement non ambitieux parce que ça
veut dire qu'on passe à côté de la vraie
bataille et la bataille vous le savez
très bien tous les scientifiques le
disent elle se joue maintenant donc oui
le pragmatisme comme élément de
l'ambition on a appris aujourd'hui que
tous les candidats de la liste hors
d'essence a dessiné un engagement à
d'abord c'est gênant même groupe au
parlement européen ce sera où ce sera
avec les verts avec les libéraux avec
les offert un groupe que nous allons
créer avec des délégations nationales
qui sont aujourd'hui membres du groupe
des libéraux et des démocrates ou doha
elle ne
les lieux où d'autres qui ne sont pas
membres aujourd'hui du groupe et qui
arriveront de manière nouvelle au
parlement européen on va ensuite
constituer ce groupe central parce que
la nouvelle donne et ça les français
doivent le comprendre c'est important ça
fait 40 ans que le parlement européen
est cogérée par les socialistes et les
conservateurs ensemble 40 ans ils ont la
majorité a eu deux donc ils se
répartissent les postes et basta pour la
première fois si j'en crois tous les
sondages aujourd'hui en europe
ça ne sera plus le cas le 26 mai donc la
donne politique va changer et nous on
sera au centre de cette nouvelle donne
politique
c'est bien pour le climat je viens d'en
parler c'est aussi bien pour la valeur
vous êtes revenu en politique vous
l'avais dit il ya un instant pour mener
tous ces combats est ce que vous êtes
également pascal canfin revenu en
politique parce que vous estimez qu'au
bout de deux ans le bilan des manuels
macro est bon je revienne et que je
repartais latine sur le de manière
générale oui
écoutez moi j'ai deux combats personnels
qui me motive et qui me font lever le
matin
le premier c'est l'écologie on a en
parlé on en reparlera je vais pas y
revenir le deuxième enfant autiste et la
construction européenne
le fait de vivre dans un monde ramper et
le fait de combattre le nationalisme
parce que partout le nationalisme c'est
la guerre ça finit toujours mal
forcément puisque vous désignez un
adversaire aux lions de construire un
bien commun c'était pas ma maison tu as
aussi parce que sur ces deux sujets sur
ces deux sujets sur l'écologie je vous
ai montré qu'elle était le bilan jus des
ong européennes du président la
république et sur l'europe
je pense qu'on peut objectivement
considéré que c'est un des chefs d'état
qui fait le plus de job
voilà c'est la fin de la première partie
messieurs merci apple vous reviendrez
tout à l'heure pour la 3è continuera de
vous interroger sur les grands enjeux
environnementaux et l'avenir de la
planète et de l'humanité mais maintenant
ce sont les deux parlementaires qui font
leur entrée sur ce plateau
alimentaire les voici donc pire laurent
sénateur communiste de paris bonsoir
bonsoir est à vos côtés raphaël jeune
berger députés aient l'air du haut rhin
bonsoir bonsoir à tous les deux une
question d'un internaute du figaro pour
vous passez quelques enfin on nous dit
que 59 % des internautes du figaro sont
prêts à privilégier le train plutôt que
l'avion pour des raisons écologiques
il y a juliette qui aimerait savoir si
vous êtes prêts à faire pareil c'est
déjà ce que je fais donc je suis
d'autant plus prêt à faire pareil que je
le fais déjà j'avais noté qu'en suède
qui est un des pays les plus avancés en
europe sur ces sujets vous avez
aujourd'hui un mouvement qui s'appelle
j'ai honte de prendre l'avion qui a fait
baisser de près de 5 à 10 points je
crois la part de marché de l'avion au
bénéfice du train vous en avez on te
prendre l'avion non mais quand c'est
nécessaire
ok mais quand on peut faire autrement
sincèrement quand ton jeu c'est vrai que
je vois encore des gens qui font paris
bordeaux en avion avec deux heures de
tgv je pense que le fait de prendre le
train plutôt que l'avion c'est un acte
qui coûte pas si cher que ça en temps
voire même pas du tout et qui a un
impact immédiat sur l'environnement vous
connaissez l'impact de ces nuisances sur
le climat quel est le poids de l'aérien
dans les émissions de co2 c'est entre 3
et 4 pour aisance et très peu dire que
vous demandiez même entre 2 et 3%
parce que parfois parler là maintenant
du forçage radiatif d emma simard haute
atmosphère
voilà je vais me présenter ça
mais aucun secteur tout seul plus que 3
ou 4%
c'est l'addition de tout ça le numérique
c'est 3 à 4% les plastiques c'est 5%
l'aviation ces trois cas de mouvements
pour dire on arrête de raids sur les
tablettes sur le plastique oui ça me
changeait ses mots ont un sens sans
rentrer dans chacun des secteurs
je pense que cette prise de conscience
écologique elle est là elle est
quasiment universels partagés
complètement mais quasiment et je m'en
réjouis
ils sont mieux et c'est tant mieux si
vous l'avez aussi je n'ai aucun problème
ce n'est pas un objet de débat politique
c'est un objet d'agrégats va voir quand
même un peu car vous allez être
interpellé monsieur vous partagez cette
conscience écologique sur l'état
d'urgence et climatiques écologiques
absolument après le débat que nous avons
c'est un débat de solutions d'accord et
je pense que les solutions qui sont
préconisées par la liste que pascal
canfin a choisi de leurs alliés ne sont
pas du tout à la hauteur
pas du tout à la hauteur du problème en
fait moi je crois que pascal canfin fait
doublement fausse route il a commencé
par dire que c'était la bonne liste pour
faire face à l'extrême droite
moi je crois que la montée des extrêmes
droites en europe et l'enfant du
libéralisme qu'on a imposé à l'europe
depuis 30 ans c'est à dire qu'à force
d'imposer des politiques de destruction
des services publics des politiques des
neg alité des politiques de captation
des richesses
on a provoqué du rejet de l'europe est
aujourd'hui la montée des nationalismes
et si on en continu enfermer le débat
entre soi les politiques libérales qui
macro est en fait celle qui sont donnés
dans l'europe aujourd'hui et l'extrême
droite
eh bien on va vers des catastrophes
politiques donc je pense qu'il faut
sortir de ça il faut faire de la place à
des vraies solutions progressistes et
notamment en matière écologique
on sait bien que face à l'urgence il
faut une autre ambition que ce que nous
a présenté le président de la république
il ya trois jours que vous venez de
défendre mais qui est tout sauf à la
hauteur de la situation en matière
écologique qu'est ce que je vous dis ça
il y avait un candidat face à marine le
pen s'était manuel macron aujourd'hui il
ya un duel entend les sondages entre la
liste que je représente renaissance et
celle du front national vous pouvez dire
que
en fait il y a pas d'opposition à
réaliser il va y avoir des gens disent y
avoir 12 lice celui dont les électeurs
auront le choix absolument et dont il
est sondage que vous chantez un avantage
donc dans les sondages que vous mettez
en avant via l'ordre 50% des électeurs
qui se déterminent pour ces deux listes
et il ya aussi des millions d'électeurs
qui pour le moment se pose la question
d'aller voter ou pas donc ils vont un
peu le jeu il ya un débat qui ne se
réduit pas à choisir soit les listes
libéral soit les listes d'extrême droite
heureusement il ya d'autres choix pour
le remblaiement d'autre choix que je
constate simplement monsieur laurent et
jeu on lit les mêmes sondages semaine
après semaine donc ils veulent dire
quelque chose
est-ce qu'il ya deux listes c'est pas
moi qui décide c'est les français qui
sont aujourd'hui au coude à coude et que
à la fin le mas non ce n'est pas votée
ces opinions s'inflige de monsieur lange
là le 26 mai il y aura soit une victoire
du nist progressiste soit une victoire
du front national 7 cette mise en scène
monsieur qu'enfin elle tend à comme
comme d'ailleurs la stratégie de
campagne de la liste sur laquelle vous
figurer à effacer a volé le choix
politiques aux français on a une
élection on est à un mois la campagne
vient seulement de commencer et vous
expliquer que c'est en gros votre liste
ou le chaos
tout ça pour une seule raison masquer le
fait que à quelques semaines vous n'avez
pas mis sur le tapis la première
proposition et notamment la banque
dernières maintiennent leur dit non à
prononcer tant craint de sortir un
certain nombre de graphiques pour
masquer un certain nombre d'incohérences
aussi vous avez présenté des chiffres
intéressants sur la stratégie de la
france historique et hérite et
d'ailleurs notamment en matière de
politique énergétique dans son impact à
l'échelle européenne un point de vue
l'émission de carbone
pourtant ça c'est pour masquer des choix
qui sont ceux du gouvernement hollande
quelques vous avez vous avez appartenu
qui sont ceux que poursuit emmanuel
macron je pense par exemple à ses choix
énergétiques qui vise à à faire tendre
notre modèle progressivement vers le
modèle allemand qui est un des plus
polluants d'europe aujourd'hui on va
dire c'est leur l'armé nucléaire c'est
le renouveau
charbon france passe une loi qui va
fermer les quatre ou cinq centrales au
charbon qu'on a en france et vous dit
qu'on est en train de s'orienter vers le
modèle allemand est encore est en crue
de charme où êtes vous avez accepté la
solution notamment sur la politique
nucléaire de nos camarades et amis
allemands que en tant que député d'une
circonscription frontalière je connais
bien maintenant mais qui la
circonscription de tain c'est ça tout
avait envoyé par scott c'est ça qui est
pb et bien qu'il ait bel juste
crédibilité juste parce que j'attends
j'attends monsieur monsieur guillon est
d'ordre et dans le m mettre sur la table
les avantages de notre système est pas
cautionner un système énergétique
allemand que ce que vous faites en
acceptant leur point de vue unique sur
le nucléaire et pour des raisons qu'on
comprend bien là de la part des
allemands qui multiplie l'ouverture des
centrales à charbon alors d'accord on va
fermer en france les quatre centrales à
charbon mais vous cautionnez par la même
occasion l'ouverture jusqu'en 2035
jusqu'en 2035 rendez vous compte
monsieur qu'enfin des centrales à
charbon allemandes
tout ça pour un câble quelques deal
électoraux qui ont pu lire quel niveau
d'accord faire la sortie du nucléaire en
allemagne elle a été décidée par
quelqu'un qui s'appelle angela merkel
qui appartient à votre famille politique
au parlement européen elle est cédée ou
avec les républicains donc d'accord
monsieur quand il faut lutter contre le
système énergétique allemand aux
systèmes énergies dire qu' il n'y a pas
de soumission à qui que ce soit et si
derrière une soumission ce serait avec
quelqu'un de votre famille politique
donc ce serait quand même assez tordu
notre pas deuxièmement nous allons
fermer c'est dans la loi de cadeaux de
présenter deux mains au conseil des
ministres
l'engagement de longue date du président
de la république les quelques centrales
à charbon qui restent en france
par ailleurs contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit le charbon n'augmente pas en
allemagne le charbon dix minutes où les
chiffres officiels le dit il ne diminue
pas assez au regard des enjeux
climatiques
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que l'allemagne
va peut-être à cause de 6 des voitures
la phrase exacte des charges insu
qu'enfin émotions il a également fallu
dix fois plus que le système français
bien fois plus il aimait beaucoup plus
de gaz à effet de serre absolument et
c'est pour ça que le sujet nuit en mer
c'est davantage du nucléaire en or mais
je n'ai jamais dit monsieur gossio
monsieur d je n'ai jamais dit que le
nucléaire et mettait des gaz à effet de
serre jamais vous ne trouverez jamais
aucune des caravanes et vous travaillez
voilà pourquoi reconstruction d'un
système vertueux ignorait dans votre
vision du monde ignorait que le charbon
d'un côté et le nucléaire de l'autre
vous oubliez un élément qui s'appelle
les énergies renouvelables aujourd'hui
la première mi-temps très tendance
angela façon massive bien sûr la
première source d'énergie en allemagne
s'était passé s'est passé l'année
dernière pour la première fois donc le
dessus le changement est en train de
s'opérer devant le charbon 40%
ce sont les énergies renouvelables vous
croyez vraiment avec la la puissance
industrielle allemande avec le savoir
faire allemand avec la compétence
technique des ingénieurs allemands que
il mettrait tous leurs oeufs dans un
panier qui serait aussi percé aussi
manger celui que vous décrivez de
stocker l'électricité
mais bien sûr les énergies champion du
stockage c'est précisément air liquide
c'est une boîte française qui teste où
ses innovations sur le stockage
d'énergie ou est-ce qu'ils le font et
ben en allemagne parce que justement eux
ils sont en train de développer la
police locale de départ du stockage de
l'énergie est ce que vous trouvez
intelligent d'engager la privatisation
des barrages hydrauliques lançons
aujourd'hui une source justement de
stockage de l'énergie parce que tout le
monde est d'accord il faut aller vers un
mix énergétique différent et il faut
faire évoluer son mix énergétique
mais pour ça il faut préserver des à
tout public
il faut construire des filières
industrielles en nous ne faisons pas
qu'est ce qu'on fait en ce moment on va
vendre les barrages hydrauliques
on est en train de couper en morceaux
edf on privatise angie on va privatiser
aéroports de paris on a mis en pièces la
sncf qui aujourd'hui découpé entre
plusieurs entreprises alors que le
ferroviaire pour lutter contre le tout
routier est un atout majeur
c'est à dire qu'on est en train de se
priver de tous les atouts cohérent et
publics dont on dont on aura besoin de
disposer pour conduire des politiques de
transition écologique ambitieuse et on
le fait au nom de quoi au nom du fait
qu'on veut continuer avec des politiques
de mise en concurrence qui sont
complètement inédit des réglementations
qui sont complètement inadaptés à
traiter l'ambition
écologique et ce faisant on se prive des
moyens nécessaires
on se prive des moyens industriels
nécessaires on se prive des savoir faire
on se prive des salariés qui saurait
nous aider à construire 7 7
cette transition énergétique et en plus
on n'est pas l'argent sur la table parce
que vous avez parlé tout à l'heure un
peu des taxes mais le grand sujet en
europe c'est quoi qu'est ce qu'on fait
de l'argent de la banque centrale
européenne pour financer autrement la
transition écologique nous nous avons
sur une proposition c'est construire un
fonds de développement européen adossé à
la banque centrale européenne financée
par l qui servent exclusivement la
transition sociale écologique et le
développement des services publics
utiles à ça or vous savez très bien que
le programme actuel du gouvernement ça
n'est pas ça c'est de continuer à
utiliser l'argent comme on le fait
aujourd'hui avec la bce c'est-à-dire
qu'on finance un système bancaire et
financier qui se moque des impératifs
écologiques par réponse alors sur sur la
bce
on se retrouvera à bruxelles et à
strasbourg pour discuter de ces sujets
et moi j'ai aucun tabou idéologique
aucun tabou qui dirait la bce ne doit
surtout pas financer la transition
écologique
donc on se retrouvera et on travaillera
ensemble sur ce sujet mais de manière
pragmatique à court terme vous alliez
aujourd'hui pascal canfin du tout ll
défendre une conception des traités et
des politiques économiques qui tourne le
dos à sa dans les traités je voulais
qu'on parle 30 secondes du mandat de la
bce dans les traités actuels d'agde dans
les traités actuels
il est écrit la bce lutte contre
l'inflation et de suite où les autres
objectifs de l'union européenne sous
réserve que ça permette le développement
durable fait partie donc à l'épaule et
je suis fière et la logique les deux
elles pourraient elles pourront jours
devant elles pourraient le même sens et
va avoir besoin monsieur le rang de
changer les traités ça c'est fondamental
ne le fait pas alors que les
gouvernements qui sont aux bahamas et
pour sous les gouvernements français et
allemand les grands ouverts mais lorsque
je vous ai vraiment pas du tout coupé la
parole est ce que vous avez lu la lettre
du président de la république aux
européens et bien sûr vous l'avez lui il
ya un paragraphe à la pression d'une
trentaine d'agents ce technocrate
l'accord on parle de la bce donc c
il traite qu'est ce qu'il dit il dit
toutes les institutions européennes y
compris la banque centrale européenne
doivent suivre le clip fin devrait avoir
pardon le climat dans leur mandat
d'accord il le dit donc je nous nous
retrouverons à bruxelles pour travailler
et sur ces sujets et tant mieux par
contre là où je vous retourne je vous
suis pas c'est l'idée que parce que
c'est public c'est bien parce que c'est
privé c'est mal edf s'est public donc
c'est forcément bien la sncf c'est
public donc c'est forcément bien et
parce qu'on veut non privatives ou
privatisées non pas du tout attendez
qu'ils avancent monsieur rocchi arkel
gouvernement a repris 35 milliards de
dette de la sncf
quel est le gouvernement qui oui mais
non mais pour m métro m ambiance
derrière la sncf est aujourd'hui
organisé la concurrence sur les soins
régionaux et singulière j'ai mis à mal
c'est rien du tout qui a été reprise
pour justement consolidé l'opérateur
public et qui va rester publique et qui
doit rester public qu'est la sncf par
contre le fait que la sncf soit publique
est-ce que ça a suffi à développer le
fret non est ce que le fait que edf voie
publique et les intermittents développer
ça a permis de développer les énergies
renouvellables pleine montée sur le
frein je ne suis pas idéologique vous
présenter avait un vieil de gaza qu'est
ce qui a changé ce qui a dilué par
l'écologie c'est qu'est ce qui est
parfois des articles en face le prix des
tickets ce qui a divisé par deux la part
des 30 du transport de marchandises par
le fret c'est la mise en concurrence du
fret
quand on a décidé la mise en concurrence
du fret la part d'un frêne étrangers
qu'on fait la lame s'est effondré alors
j'ai tout à la pointe sur ce sujet à
quelques enfin si j'entends votre
divergences idéologiques ce que vous
vous estimez que le capitalisme
je marchais les entreprises privées le
capitalisme peut être au coeur de la
transition écologique d'heure mondial de
l'efficacité énergétique des
technologies d'efficacité énergétique
c'est schneider boîte française
le leader mondial de l'hydrogène demain
air liquide boîtes françaises privées le
leader mondial de la mobilité électrique
aujourd'hui c'est l'alliance renault
nissan doit être
bien peu de participation de l'état mais
essentiellement privés c'est pas des
boîtes public et puis si je prends de
l'autre côté gazprom russe public 100%
public un grand leader de la transition
écologique saudi aramco saoudien 100%
public de grand leader de la transition
et que d'idéologie mais on n'est pas si
riche on est passé un peu vite sur un
élément en citant la lettre des manuels
macron by passant toutes les
organisations institutionnelles ou aux
autres états européens
il faut faire tout ce qui est
intéressant il serait technique parce
que ça parce que justement et polis
parce que justement parce que justement
dans sa lettre sous couvert d'une
démarche inédite
il défend une organisation dont
aujourd'hui ni les français ni les
européens ne veulent
il défend la création et la
multiplication des agences
technocratique confié à une bourrique à
une bureaucratie autonomiser donc plus
personne ne veut aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les français les européens
ils veulent des responsables ils veulent
des politiques qui agissent en proposant
la création d' agences et en les
multipliant en proposant lé
élargissement sans fin à la roumanie à
l'albanie aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
propre aux européens et aux français une
europe qui est justement celle dont on
ne veut plus qui est justement celle qui
ne fonctionne plus aujourd'hui il faut
être clair il faut une europe qui sache
dire qui est laid quelles sont ses
limites et qui redeviennent une europe
politique pour que les choix des
citoyens soit opérant ça n'est pas du
tout ce que vous proposez avec la
multiplication des agences
bureaucratiques qui figure dans la
lettre des manuels agence l'agent ce qui
autorise les médicaments sur le mise sur
le marché
vous trouvez que c'est technocratique
vous trouvez que c'est sain que ce soit
pas liée aux politiques qu'elle veut y
répondre elle répondait à 5 c'est une
exposition c'est un exemple après zidane
henry y ont cru mais quand vous proposer
sur les questions énergétiques qui a pas
de mutisme alors que c'est justement des
choix politiques qui doivent être faits
la nôtre un autre exemple
alors qui est beaucoup moins arrangeants
pour votre démonstration pas du tout
c'est j'écoute et si vous voulez que
justement que les choses ne soient pas
en permanence politisé par des intérêts
nationaux
parfois il faut savoir effectivement
confier à une autorité à força regza
politise
non les politiques veulent mettre en
oeuvre des choix des citoyens bien sûr
mais vous ne proposez pas avec la
nouvelle organisation institutionnelle
qui est très dense de bureaux parisiens
toujours plus de ce qui ne fonctionne
pas ouais franchement je ne suis pas
convaincu parce que il veut tous les
sujets on peut les prendre un par un on
va le faire à chaque fois il ya une
bonne raison de le faire on dont nous
devrons nous on développe pas une
nouvelle institution pour développer une
nouvelle institution bien évidemment je
suis comme vous j'ai pas envie de payer
des impôts pour rien je suis pour que
l'état soit efficace pourquoi vous ne
préfériez ce procès donc si on le fait
c'est parce qu'on pense que justement il
faut pour que ça marche pour que ça
marche dans l'intérêt des européens
il faut le sortir des jeux qui sont
parfois des jeux de marchands de tapis
entre les états pour le confier à une
autorité indépendante par exemple les
médicaments par exemple la protection
des consommateurs maintenons une une des
agences qu'on veut créer c'est
l'équivalent de la direction de la
répression des fraudes en europe parce
que vous avez vu il ya quelques semaines
en pologne
vous avez eu vous avez eu un scandale de
la viande avariée pourquoi ce scandale a
été étouffée d'abord parce que justement
c'est le gouvernement polonais comme
partie vos alliés qui ont étouffé ce
scandale parce qu'il n'y a pas d'
agences indépendantes en pologne puis un
journal indépendant heureusement qu'il
en reste encore quelques-uns qui a sorti
cette affaire et tout d'un coup il ya la
commission européenne qui a dit mme
attendait c'est scandaleux et en france
parce qu'on a un système qui est
efficace pour la répression des fraudes
on a réussi à faire en sorte que les
consommateurs français de service public
extrêmement efficace et donc voyez ça
marche comme ça parce qu'en s'est
politisée quand c'est derrière les
intérêts nationaux et la concurrence
généralement c'est le consommateur et le
citoyen qui va et il vous a fusions
entre siemens entre siemens et alstom on
peut en parler on pense que c'est une
volonté de technocratie c'est d'ailleurs
par la commissaire européen par la
commissaire européen qui est celle issue
du groupe auquel avec lequel vous vous
apprêtez à siéger citant bien qu'on ait
compris que vous allez bien siéger avec
avec les libéraux ce qui semble clair
parce que forme la grue battre les gars
en fonction d'un paysage politique
européen qui n'existe pas pour masquer
votre isolement sur la scène politique
retient personne on y croit
ne tirez pas trop de plomb sur la comète
sur qui gouvernera elle qui parce que
vous risquez le groupe
mais voici j'ai les députés de en marche
et les vôtres risque de continuer à
cogérer ensemble la commission en scène
demain c'est assez probable étonnant
néolithique européenne n'existait pas
quand vous faites partie du parti
populaire européen le jeu fut pas des
plus grands partis jeudi et dès que vous
voulez vous la pile expliqué qu'ils
aient la même chance est au parlement
repères de ce poisson n'ayant que vous
le croyez donc au bilan qu'elle
corresponde à ce qui vous arrangerait
bivalente ces messieurs s'est terminée
vous avez démontré qu'on est
effectivement bien en campagne
électorale on accord suit le combat des
idées aussi ce sera difficile comme tous
vous réunir sur les grands enjeux du
climat merci beaucoup d'être venu
d'avoir participé à cette audition
publique tout de suite la dernière
partie de l'émission avec brigitte
boucher et le retour de paul au
brouillard
pendant qu'il s'installe une question de
gènes c'est un internaute du figaro il
s'intéresse au parc aquatique il cite le
cas de nausicaa vous connaissez sur mer
et de marineland à antibes
alors le premier il a un problème avec
ces requins marteaux ils meurent
d'infections apparemment le second est à
nouveau contesté par des associations
qui dénoncent les conditions de vie
notamment des dauphins à l'étroit dans
leur bassin est ce qu'il faut fermer les
parcs aquatiques
très sincèrement je n'ai pas d'avis
politique sur le sujet je peux avoir un
avis personnel je préfère les animaux
dans la nature
voilà mais c'est pas un sujet politique
nausicaa que je connais bien un boulogne
ça permet aussi de faire découvrir la
beauté de l'océan aux enfants de la
région des hautes france et de partout
donc il faut trouver le bon équilibre
entre les deux aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de propositions politiques sur le sujet
de fermeture ou de modification du
fonctionnement de ces centres
brigitte pascal canfin bonjour les
experts de la biodiversité sont réunis
aujourd'hui à paris un million
d'insectes qui serait qui serait menacée
ce serait la sixième extinction de masse
mais dû cette fois à l'homme alors
est-ce qu'il faut un accord
international contraignant sur la
biodiversité comme il existe sur le
climat tout à fait que la réponse est
oui si cette réunion des scientifiques
de la biodiversité qui est l'équivalent
du giec pour le climat
enfin pour l'ania pour le climat c'est
aussi important si se réunissent
aujourd'hui à paris n'est pas le fruit
du hasard c'est parce que le
gouvernement français à l'époque
à l'initiative de nicolas hulot a
demandé à ce que cette réunion ait lieu
à paris parce que il y a une volonté du
gouvernement français d'avoir un
leadership international pour aboutir
exactement ce que vous venez d'écrire
c'est à dire un accord international de
protection de la vie sauvage et de la
biodiversité qui sera trouvée en chine
en 2020 je l'espère comme on a trouvé à
paris en 2015
la colle accord sur le climat dans
l'école d'un tiers donc c'est le pendant
puisqu'il ya deux grandes crises
environnementales majeures le climat
tout le monde en a entendu parler
- la disparition de la vie sauvage peut
être un chiffre qui est plus sorti des
rapport du wwf donc que je connais bien
depuis exactement depuis 40 ans sur ces
40 dernières années 60% des animaux
sauvages ont disparu qu'on parle des
abeilles
qu'on parle des gorilles qu'on parle des
mésanges voilà est-ce qu'on peut se
satisfaire d'un monde où en 40 ans on a
détruit 60 % de la vie sauvage de quel
droit
fêtons ça parce que c'est le même combat
que je mène depuis voilà que je menais
ow2 je le mène aujourd'hui on va réussir
à trouver l'accord international et la
france est aujourd'hui
évidemment nous porterons ça au
parlement européen c'est une évidence
absolue et par ailleurs nous portons
aussi pourquoi la nature disparaît elle
disparaît parce que il ya une cause
principale cause c'est la déforestation
la déforestation il vient de quoi elle
vient de notre consommation alimentaire
notamment de soja et d'huile de la balle
est donc on défendra ce que la france a
déjà fait pour elle même c'est à dire
une stratégie de lutte contre la
déforestation dit importer ses planchers
du mois chez nous exactement à ça au
brésil exactement mais elle se passe
chez nous après avoir tenu sa
continuelle exactement malheureusement
et se passe chez nous à travers quoi
à travers nos achats et donc par exemple
des achats de biocarburants voulait
interdire le nutella en fait ne veut pas
interdire le niqab a par contre on veut
faire en sorte que la culture de soja et
la culture d'une de palme quand elle ne
peut pas être remplacée par une culture
locale puisque le soja on pourrait très
bien le faire en france on n'est pas
favorable avec jérémy de serbes qui
vient du président des facs et ancien
président des jeunes agriculteurs et qui
est aussi ce qui a surpris et c'est ça
qui est génial c'est que ça a surpris
parce que culturellement en france on
divise et on oppose tout le temps et si
on veut gagner si on veut changer les
choses il faut pas diviser il faut
rassembler et moi c'est vraiment ce qui
m'a séduit c'est pour ça que je suis sur
cette liste c'est parce que c'est une
liste qui rassemble autour d'un projet
clair sur l'agriculture avec jérémy
decerle on a deux histoires différentes
mais on converge pour changer des choses
vraiment là où ça se joue avec la
politique agricole commune et les
communes dont calais européenne de la
serbie faisait justement pas du tout il
l'a dit plusieurs fois il est pour qu'
on puisse sortir du glyphosate en trois
ans en france en cinq ans en europe
puisque c'est la décision qui a été
prise
encore faut-il alam encore faut-il que
les agriculteurs et les solutions
alternatives
ce que je peux vous dire 'ok on sort du
glyphosate et puis en fait aujourd'hui
moment on parle l'agricul qu'il
alternatif chimiques les pires donc
s'agit pas de faire des injonctions sur
les plateaux télé voisins
op l'utilisent et privés 50 % à 50 % du
glyphosate qui utilisaient en france les
dans les vignes dans les vignes c'est du
vin français n'a pas délocalisé le vin
français ailleurs donc il s'agit de
trouver territoire par territoire
terroir par terroir culture par culture
toutes les solutions alternatives pour
en sortir c'est exactement ça notre
feuille de route commune et c'est très
très important que les écologistes et
les agriculteurs le façon sans colle
selon vous pascal canfin combien de
temps il reste avant comparé un pur pour
qu'on puisse stopper la catastrophe
climatique annoncée d'abord qu'il est
encore temps pour renverser la vapeur
très honnêtement et j'aimerais beaucoup
vous dira le contraire je pense qu'il
est en partie déjà trop tard pour éviter
une partie du choc climatique
on est déjà un degré 2 3 de
réchauffement climatique les scénarios
si on continue ce qu'on appelle
'business as usual' si on ne change rien
on est sur trois et demi quatre voire
cinq degrés de réchauffement climatique
c'est quelque chose qui est inimaginable
et donc il est déjà en partie ce retard
parce que ça dure qu'elle ne sera pas
non parce que c'est les deux valeurs
c'est un point 5 2 degrés donc il faut
agir maintenant et c'est pour ça que je
m'engage maintenant parce que c'est plus
on attend chaque jour qui passe chaque
mois qui passe c'est un mois de perdu
donc il faut agir maintenant de manière
efficace et des trams at il déjà trop
tard comme on limite la casse
comment ben justement par exemple la
banque quel est le sujet d'abord le
sujet c'est comment on finance la
transition donc la banque européenne du
climat comment on lève tous les
obstacles qui font que oui les
agriculteurs peuvent vraiment changer le
modèle économique
oui les champions industriels dont on
parlait tout à l'heure l'energy
les michelin est un liquide les
schneider electric sur des champions
industriels français et tant mieux
puisse déployer leurs technologies pour
aller vers un monde bas carbone est ce
que quand vous écoutez c'était une fille
dans ce tête que les colobes slogan
raison comme mon combat de tous les
jours c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte
qu'il n'est pas raison à la fin mais je
ne peux pas vous dire en vous regardant
dans les yeux en regardant les français
dans les yeux que on va évidemment
éviter la catastrophe climatique non on
s'y dirige on s'y dirige et c'est pour
ça que je suis engagé en catastrophe ce
qu elle pas la catastrophe climatique
c'est des centaines de millions de
migrants climatiques
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour la
capacité de l'europe mais pas seulement
l'europe de l'ensemble des pays
africains par exemple à gérer ça pour
l'inde avec le pakistan etc
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
évidemment dire des conflits ça veut des
linéaires mon pull de chaos plus
d'insécurité
c'est un des éléments la catastrophe
climatique quand on parle de l'amour de
l'extinction des espèces là on parle de
d'extinction de l'espèce humaine au c
non je n'irai pas jusque là parce que je
pense que là ce serait excessif je pense
qu'on parle d'un monde où on ne pourront
pour a pas non plus difficilement vivre
en paix en prospérité de manière stable
et c'est pour ça que les entreprises
s'engagent aussi dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique parce que
beaucoup d'entre elles ont maintenant
compris parce qu'elle n'avait pas
forcément compris avant elles ont
compris maintenant que un monde à 3 4 5
degrés de réchauffement climatique c'est
un monde où faire des affaires faire du
business prospérait faire des profits
est ce que ce sera pacifique est
davantage les chefs d'entreprise
justement qui veulent mettre au coeur
finalement de leur politique
je pense que je pense moi ce que je
pousse comme proposition aujourd'hui
précisément c'est que aujourd'hui dont
20 milliards d'investissements je
l'évoqué dans les parties précédentes de
l'émission en france pour financer à
l'échelle de ce qu'il faut faire pour
respecter l'accord de paris les la
grille que la transition agricole la
transition énergétique l'isolation des
bâtiments l'achat de véhicules plus
propres et ses 20 milliards
d'investissements il faut mobiliser tout
le monde et donc moi je suggère que le
premier ministre le président de la
république dans ce fameux conseil de
défense écologique où il va réunir une
partie du gouvernement mais aussi
l'ensemble des acteurs clés autour et
bien organise rapidement cette réunion
avec les grands acteurs économiques
de façon à fixer ce que chacun peut et
doit faire island sénatoriales et 20000
à combien devrait contribuer les
entreprises mais c'est pas ça une
question de contribution quand je vous
disais là vous raisonner en termes de
taxation moi je vous dis en termes de
solution si on est capable de changer
les règles du jeu pour que l'isolation
des bâtiments de nos logements ou des
bureaux ou des bâtiments publics
ça fonctionne enfin je rappelle juste un
objectif 500 milles objectif au public
cinq cent mille bâtiments isolés c'était
vrai sous nicolas sarkozy le fameux
grenelle de l'environnement complètement
échoué
on a refixé exactement le même objectif
sous françois hollande complètement raté
on refixe le même objectif soit emmanuel
macron et on n'est toujours pas en train
de l'atteindre
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut changer de
méthode et c'est pour ça que la
conférence de citoyens que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure décidé et annoncé
quelques jours par le président de la
république et ce fameux conseil de
défense écologique
c'est un changement profond de méthode
parce qu'au fond aujourd'hui et c'est la
bonne nouvelle si je balance un petit
peu j'équilibre un petit peu ce que je
vous disais sur ma crainte profonde une
un vrai choc
il ya une catastrophe climatique on a
toutes les solutions aujourd'hui c'est
extraordinaire notre génération est la
première génération a parlé sous lui
même ne tient pas ses objectifs la
production de 50% d'électricité d'un à
pain du nucléaire d'électricité à 50% a
été décalée de 10 ans à 2035 au lieu de
2012 dit moi même quand j'étais au wwf
que je trouvais ce report normal
pourquoi parce que on avait pris du
retard partie ment on a pris du retard à
l'allumage c'est encore plus difficile
d'y aller donc il ya quelques instants
on trouvait que faire que c'était on
allait beaucoup beaucoup trop vite ça
c'était la position du député des
républicains vous me dites vous allez
beaucoup trop lentement bon je pense que
quelque part c'est que c'est le bon
chemin là où c'est moi ce graphique il
est très simple c'est celui des ong
environnementales à bruxelles bon jodie
mais en troisième position
voilà c'est pas assez je voulais dit
mais c'est quand même pas mal
par exemple j'ai parlé aussi des citoyen
aujourd'hui on assiste à de
nouvelle manette et par de nouvelles
expressions précisément sur ces
questions de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
ça vous inspire quoi on assiste à des
radicalités à des gens qui sont dans la
désobéissance civile c'est ainsi qu'ils
se nomment mon occupation des banques et
puis on a aussi ce domaine nouveau d'une
adolescente suédoise
le greta d'une berline égéries comme ça
mondiale vous avez quoi de la tendresse
pour ce genre de chose de l'intérêt de
la tradition les mouvements d'ailleurs
c'est y pas pourquoi pas parce qu'elle
est contestée par certains écologistes
qui estiment qu'elle est manipulée par
exemple par l'industrie des énergies
alternatives 1 d'accord je pense par
exemple à l'ancien député que vous
connaissez bien il s'appellerait tard
qu'ils disent à dell de la seule trois
de ses emballages voyez typiquement
c'est intéressant c'est que on est
toujours dans clivages et la
différenciation et la critique
moi je vais toujours ça a toujours été
ma ligne j'abrège j'avance et on fédère
et on change les choses évidemment c'est
formidable l'appel qu'a lancé greta ça a
bougé les lignes et évidemment c'est
formidable que la jeunesse se mobilise
comme jamais sur ces sujets c'est
extraordinaire on a besoin de cette
énergie
c'est super qu'il y ait deux millions de
citoyens français qui est signé la
pétition pour attaquer l'état pour une
action il n'attaque pas le gouvernement
ils attaquent l'état l'état actuel mais
l'état 10 à 50 à 10 ans pour une action
climatique
ça fait changer ouais mais je pense que
je vais me donner ma réponse personnelle
je pense qu'on a besoin de cette énergie
on a besoin de ça pour changer les
lignes bousculé les conservatismes
avancé pour transformer notre modèle de
production vivre mieux polluer moins
respirer un air moins pollué et simon
agrégeant cette énergie qu'on y arrivera
en vous même la désobéissance civile la
question est à cause de vous a prouvé
par exemple l'envahissement des banques
qui financent les énergies fossiles
encore une fois ce que je n'approuve pas
c'est la violence la désobéissance
civile elle et elle tend à être parent
pança dans son idéologie dans sa vision
du monde celles de gandhi par exemple
non violente
la désobéissance civile non violente en
dix ans j'alerte sur une menace qui nous
concerne tous on n'est pas en train de
réagir à la gambie pour être précis j'ai
déjà surgères jours
j'hallucine de la défense avec ce que
j'avais fait des études sociales un
projet est important que la jeunesse que
la société civile se mobilise et fasse
contrepoids aux lobbys fasse contrepoids
aux lobbys et moi je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est une déclaration qu'on
a signé on ne vous savez déposer la
liste renaissance et vous verrez dans le
programme on a signé aujourd'hui nous
déclarerons tous les rendez vous que
nous aurons au parlement européen avec
les groupes de représentants d'intérêts
autrement dit les lobbys
nous les rendrons public même si nous ne
sommes pas obligés retenu de le voir
dans le feront parce qu'à ressent aussi
d'être enlevé des actions spectaculaires
quand elles sont pacifiques donc vous
devez à ce qu'ont également rejoint jeu
et je note je note que quand il y avait
des dizaines de milliers de français
très jeunes pour la plupart qui faisait
la grève pour le climat et qui le
lendemain le samedi ont manifesté pour
le climat c'était dans une non violence
totale en face il y avait des gilet
jaune qui eux étaient dans une violence
maximum et ça pour le coup tout d'un
coup plus personne n'en parle moi je
désapprouve je suis désolée autant là
les revendications peuvent être
parfaitement légitime autant les modes
d'action ne peuvent pas laisser le
numéro deux le geste renaissance
approuvé un autre type d'action alors
non violent ce sont ces commandos qui
font irruption dans les mairies pour
décrocher le portrait du chef de l'état
ça vous l'approuvez les c est ce que
j'approuve ça je sais pas que ça
existait vous avez raison
moi réponse s'il pense que c'est comme
ça s'ils pensent que ces gens si si
c'est non violent et s'il pense que
c'est vraiment ça l'enjeu essentiel de
la démocratie française aujourd'hui de
du monde qu'il le fasse qu'il le fasse à
moi je pense que fondamentalement ça
n'apporte aucune solution ça ne génère
aucune mobilisation collective
mais après tout ce qu'il le fasse on est
en démocratie le projet de loi énergie
climat sera présenté demain vous l'avais
dit en conseil des ministres il avait
été retoqué une première fois parce
qu'il était insuffisamment ambitieux
est-ce que vous avez des informations à
nous communiquer sur
je vous vois un petit peu venir là
donc la réponse est non la communication
du gouvernement sur ce sujet et demi
tandis que ce soit de rugy le fera et ce
qui est un élément important c'est le
fait de mettre dans la loi la fermeture
des centrales à charbon puisque le
gouvernement a dit qu'il allait faire
puis certains ont dit bah finalement ils
ne vont pas le faire avec c'était un
clin là c'est clairement gravé dans le
marbre
on parlait comme les centrales à charbon
mais sur le nucléaire par exemple vous
vous disais qu'il fallait un calendrier
accéléré le calendrier de fermeture
sauf qu'un canal y aura que deux
réacteurs à fessenheim sont fermés oui
bah déjà pré crise y est déjà
à titre personnel moi je pense qu'il
fallait le plus vite possible
d'accord et la décision fondamentale
pour le nucléaire si on a 30 secondes
sur le sujet c'est pas celle là parce
que c'est là en gros à l'échelle de
l'histoire qu'on ferme trois quatre
centrales en cinq ans ou en ces temps et
c'est la tendance elle est claire on va
les fermer et donc le sujet c'est
comment on traite l'accompagnement
social des salariés et nous ce que je
pense que je porte depuis le début avec
laurent berger le patron de la cfdt
c'est un contrat de transition
écologique qui non seulement couvre les
territoires ça c'est déjà le cas c'est
ce que le gouvernement a fait avec
nicolas hulot à l'époque mais aille plus
loin encore c'est à dire couvre les
personnes quand vous n'êtes pas
forcément salariés d'edf parce que vous
savez c'est un contrat quand même
contrainte à ses protecteurs le statut
d'edf
en revanche les sous traitants c'est
plus compliqué et donc il faut moi c'est
ma proposition
ces consignes avec chacun d'entre eux
les salariés un contrat de transition
écologique de façon à ce que ça sécurise
leur transition nécessaire la transition
écologique elle est nécessaire mais il
n'y a aucune raison que les salariés qui
travaillaient dans le charbon et moi mon
grand père il était mineur de fond dans
pas de calais donc la sortie du charbon
il ya aucune raison qu'il en paye le
prix humainement lui donc il faut un
contrat de transition écologique pour ce
soir à tout accord ambitieux et juste
alors le premier ministre présente les
mains des mesures il va mettre en
musique bien sûr les annonces du chef de
l'état notamment à propos des niches
fiscales
qui vont être revus oui j'ai celle qui
touche les entreprises les ménages nous
savons faire toucher edouard philippe a
précisé que le cic serait maintenu
également le crédit impôt recherche
seulement un peu dans le sens de vos
attentes puisque vous misez beaucoup
vous aussi sur l'innovation
c'est une bonne chose de maintenir cette
niche fiscale oui il faut regarder
niches fiscales tony chan et le crédit
impôt recherche je suis pas un
technicien dans l'efficacité de chaque
fils ni moi j'essaie de parler de ce que
je connais donc ce que je peux vous dire
c'est de manière générale l'equilibre
consistant à dire on va enlever des
niches fiscales aux entreprises pour
permettre la baisse des impôts des
particuliers et notamment des classes
moyennes et les classes populaires
je pense que c'était évidemment une
bonne opère une bonne bonne voie parce
qu'enfin moins d'un an des municipales
les décisions sont pas forcément
gouvernementale pas votre si précisément
à l'échelon local
aujourd'hui certains élus parisiens on
préconise est ce que votre périphérique
parisien passe à 50 km heure d'autres
candidats à la mairie de paris nous même
sa destruction sa sa démolition
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire par rapport à
ce problème alors de pollution majeure
bon honnêtement moi je suis candidat aux
européennes les européennes sinon trois
semaines et donc si on peut se focaliser
sur les européennes d'abord et ensuite
on parlera des municipales une question
d'environnement c'est vous dire que
j'allais vous dira donc si le sujet
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait pour lutter
contre la pollution de l'air alors là je
peux vous répondre sur qu'est ce qu'on
propose en europe et quelle est
l'importance de l'europe qui fixe les
règle sur les carburants
on sait que la pollution de l'air ces
deux choses c'est le charbon allemand
notamment qui vient chez nous nous
polluer pour ça qu'il faut cette
transition écologique forte et d'autre
part ces particules fines du diesel les
normes sur les carburants
c'est l'europe donc mon combat j'ai
aucun avis sur les sujets je ne suis pas
candidat à paris donc je ne répondrai
pas à cette question je suis candidat
pour baisser les normes d'émission des
particules fines des constructeurs
automobiles pour notre santé pour les
personnes âgées pour nos enfants
dernière seconde
l'occasion de répondre à la question de
brigitte par oui ou par non non est ce
que total peut être sponsor des jo de
2024 anne hidalgo s'y opposent parce que
ne répond pas à des critères écologiques
je pense que ce serait pas assez ce
serait pas très cohérent je vais être
très honnête avec vous ce serait pas
très cohérent avec l'ambition qui a été
fixé par un hidalgo justement qui est
d'avoir les jeux compatibles avec la cox
et c'est donc les bretons voilà c'est
dit merci à vous merci à vous pour les
deux merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
cette semaine encore à la semaine
prochaine